Pues como tú bien decías segunda parada
de Olaf slove en esta gira Sudamericana
ya pasaron por el museo de la memoria y
eso indica que Esto va a ser uno de los
temas principales que lo diferencian
frente a las visitas en Argentina y la
prevista en Brasil el tema de los
Derechos Humanos la colonia dignidad esa
colonia que Data de la dictadura en el
centro sur de chile que fue dirigida por
un alemán nazi y en la que se cometieron
muchos tipos de abusos contra los
derechos humanos y en la que todavía no
sean propuesto indemnizaciones
suficientes para muchas de esas víctimas
entre ellas muchos niños que sufrieron
abusos sexuales y también que nacieron
sin saber por ejemplo el nombre de sus
padres ese será uno de los temas
centrales junto a otro de los temas
también tratados en Argentina Como por
ejemplo el desarrollo del hidrógeno
verde el que chile se encuentra a la
cabeza debido a su situación especial
que le permite producir energías
renovables a un bajo costo a su
desarrollo en energía solar el hidrógeno
verde se produce a través de energías
renovables Católica y solar y sabemos
que Alemania está muy preocupada en este
momento por el desarrollo y por el
suministro de nuevos tipos de energías
debido al conflicto con Ucrania Que
también será uno de los temas que se
Tratará junto al cambio climático y los
problemas asociados con esta temática en
el que también chile ha mostrado
iniciativas de renombre mundial Esta es
la agenda prevista lo sabremos más en
las próximas horas cuando se produzca la
conferencia de prensa